uh we all love iger well why did he go
on a run
iger is arguably the most powerful
person in hollywood
media sports and toys
okay he's got espn gotcha esp star wars
toys yes
abc which had two of the top 10 most
watched
things in 2019 both football
both football super bowl what do they
have they had the college football
national championship and one of the
college football final four games it
uh and he's got baby yoda he's got baby
victoria
right he's got a streaming network that
has taken off in just a few months
i think disney plus is like the national
parks it is just a wonderful public
service
seven bucks a month have you seen that
library that is hilarious
the fact that they came out at seven
dollars i thought they were going to
come out at like
12 or a 10 maybe they came out at seven
i was like this is gonna go right to 250
million subs yeah and you know
what other service has had 250 million
subs before nothing
nothing correct trick question it's like
verizon
over 100 million subs no this aol hits
35 million
well netflix 150 50 right right yeah
nobody's ever had a service that
got to a billion subs but yeah i think
it'll be a billion subs in 10 years
20 years we'll be sitting here there'll
be a billion one in seven people on the
planet that's
incredible thing about disney it's like
non-partisan
everyone loves disney it could be a
dollar a month if there were a billion
people on it they could make 12 billion
a year at a dollar a month per user you
could make it 12
a year and they can jack up the prices
then at the theme parks right i mean
they can lead with this kind of a thing
back to what 1937 or something when walt
disney drew up that thing
the lego system oh yeah the ego says
characters in the middle
the theme parks over here the toys over
there the musicals down here yeah the
movies right there
yeah it's unbelievable pretty much the
same yeah yeah ip
it's amazing it's just writers actually
it's the writers at disney who are
creating this unbelievable eye page i
had an idea for this
when i read about that i just thought
and i actually thought about kurosawa
the japanese director there there's
biography something like an
autobiography touhou studios used to own
the director and the writers um the
producers the lighting it was all the
same company
so it's like you went to work every day
and people punched in and one of the
people punching was an actor
i'm a funny another person checking it
was akira kurosawa the
director and they would just make movies
they'd say yeah let's make this movie
next like
this they were just going to work every
day making movies they weren't like
working in hollywood where they would
you know get hired to do one movie and i
just thought somebody should just get a
100 million dollar like venture fund
and just hire every comic book artist
and just say
here's a building in a beautiful place
here's you know whatever it is
five hundred thousand dollars a year
which is probably create and just make
characters that's business all day this
is the imagineers
isn't that what they're called the
imaginators oh and imaginations at
disney yeah they just make sense and
when they couldn't and they couldn't
meet those goals what did they do they
went out and acquired
a bunch of things like marvel and star
wars to mix it up they're gonna say
they've fired those writers
no no those are great various disney
incredible writers but they built up the
whole
content asset base they didn't drive the
ecosystem fire those writers dude that's
so cool
i'm just thinking what do you think
serving that lemonade frozen lemonade
remember tom hanks says walt disney and
saving mr banks yes it's a delightful
movie isn't it it's great
absolutely delightful who's the uh
reminds me it's almost as delightful as
like the
light driver yeah paul giamatti finally
somebody saw the lighthouses
i'm scared you saw it right yeah it's
scary
the lighthouse was dark yeah it was
intense and it was awkward
oh very awkward like there are lots of
awkward moments
you're uncomfortable the entire time
wait is this william defoe yes willem
dafoe and uh the batman
oh the batman or are you gonna say the
vampire the batman okay what's that his
name again
um the question bail no no not as cool
not as neat oh um he was in the vampire
movies and now we're gonna get a
millennial joke thrown away in a second
um
twilight movies yeah that's why i like
kids yeah i met him in hollywood he's
cool kid
nice guy uh but bob our buddy bob
i didn't meet him with bob iger no he's
in the fourth harry potter
no he's not yeah he is that
christian bell is not in oh we're not
talking about christian people no no
i'm just mixing i'm totally mixing
batman's up
um what the heck is that kid's name nick
you're the prince
pattinson rpat my boy our pat
uh really nice guy though um so tiger
man
iger is gone tiger tiger's gone but he's
not going anywhere he's staying for
another year
his stock went crazy people are a little
scared yeah
but i dropped six percent yesterday
which is double what the market went
down i guess
something like that yeah he's been on
for 15 years the stock price is five
times higher than when he took over at
the hill right
he led the company through cord cutting
the financial crisis
right and he got star wars pixar and
marvel yeah which are
which is bonkers and he bought those all
for what two to five million
last time you were on an airplane was
there not every seat watching an
avengers movie i think it's the most
watched thing i've ever dealt with
yes seat back every seat back is end
game and
not only did he buy those assets he has
scaled them i mean how many what have
they done with star wars they came out
with like one every what
two decades and now there's the star
wars purists are not happy about it